leute es gab auch die wildesten gerüchte
darüber warum ich jetzt auf einmal keine
videos aufnehmen kann unter anderem auf
das sich laut unfall hatte aber dem war
nicht so nennen wie gesagt hatte ich
einfach
servus es geht willkommen zurück ich bin
wieder back in business wie wieder in
der lage aufzunehmen und wir zocken
heute einfach mal fragen auf mein name
mit zig mal ein paar enten und erkläre
ich auch mal was bisher passiert ist
rassist rassist wir sehen uns gleich
eine widerlich bin heute quick sowie
games es gibt einiges zu erzählen viele
von euch wissen ja bestimmt nicht was
bei mir passiert ist warum jetzt paar
wochen keine video von mir selbst kam
sondern von max werde ich euch heute
alles erklären hier sieht vielleicht
hier dieses micro ist ein fußball das
ist das von max ich nehme
juli bei also 20 mitarbeitern sehr genau
werden
ich habe auch in mein ganzes leben als
eine runde kriegstage games gespielt
deswegen gewonnen
die habe ich direkt gewonnen und zwar
leute ging das alles so ich habe extreme
lex gehabt an meinem rechner ja ich weiß
gar nicht woran das lag ich glaube wir
haben eine vermutung ist dass es an der
roccat kone lag die soll ab und zu mal
den pc richtig auseinander nehmen hat
mal zu mir gemeint und da keine ahnung
also ist nicht geklärt aber jetzt kann
ich warte warte ich habe block mit dem
auto ist ein team ok moment die wir
heute noch ein bisschen was an botschaft
bedenken müssen messstation und ja genau
und dann war einfach gelegt ich konnte
nicht mehr richtig aufnehmen
und da habe ich gedacht das kann es
einfach nicht sein
somit hat collex dreierteam
mist geworden direct x na ja auf jeden
fall das ja auch noch nicht so wichtig
als man muss auch mal den spielmodus
wieder reifen wir gehen einfach mal die
nächste runde
wie gesagt hat auf einmal voll die
heftigen lex und ich wusste gar nicht
woran das lag und konnte nicht erklären
ich konnte nichts dagegen machen
ich habe alles durchgeschaut fraps
audacity was auch sein könnte ich habe
es einfach nicht herausgefunden was ist
dann natürlich gleich max mach mal die
videos da bis ich wieder ja bis ich
wieder dann an einem geschalten kümmert
aufnehmen kann euch neben max rechner
auf ja so ok an rhein elbe direkt los
und ja genau ich habe mich jetzt mein
semester abgeschlossen das zweite
semester ist vorbei und ich geh jetzt
wieder eineinhalb monate zu hause und
kann jetzt hier alles mache ich das
gedacht
ich kann alles machen ich kann ihr live
stream ich kann videos machen bis zum
verrecken und ich freue mich richtig
drauf weil wie gesagt jetzt einfach erst
mal zeit habe ich hatte sonst immer in
die klausuren hausarbeiten pipapo wieso
das war ja klar der hat mein geld
genauso
in kleinen abschlag des ok abstauber
aber so geht es ja auch glaube ich so
ist es ganz normal abstauben abstauben
abgestaubt werden
leute es gab auch die wildesten gerüchte
darüber warum ich jetzt auf einmal keine
videos aufnehmen kann unter anderem auf
dass sich ein autounfall hatte aber dem
war nicht so nennen wie gesagt hatte ich
einfach technische probleme und konnte
da nicht so wirklich was machen dass
vegf weiter in die nächste runde
das ist ganz cool dieses kriegs wie
games ist es halt echt quick wer hätte
es gedacht wurde so recht zu würdigen es
ist echt 200 zweifel games kann keine
gentechnik kein fake mit gen mais von
monsanto monsanto ihr [ __ ] okay
jetzt werde verklagt
extra und extrem skrupellos in dem was
die machen und ich mir ist die
gentechnik nicht so ganz geheuer muss
ich sagen und das liegt nicht daran dass
ich irgendwie besonders religiös
mitunter bedenken habe dass da in gottes
schöpfung angegriffen wird aber ich habe
einfach wenn da irgendwas schief läuft
oder irgendwie konsequenzen nicht nicht
sagen
präventiv verhindert werden können dann
kann er einiges schieflaufen als jetzt
nicht in richtung zombie apokalypse oder
so aber sich das manche vielleicht
vorstellen ich hab kein schwert sondern
einfach rein das also monsanto hat als
ich hat sich auch schon in anderen
angelegenheit nicht mit ruhm bekleckert
ich glaube pcb war auch der sohn ist so
ein giftiges material was in
kühlschränken war ich glaube das gab es
war auch monsanto und haben die einen
ganzen ort also die hatten so ein pcb
werk unserem ort und der ganze ort ist
jetzt komplett verseucht also mit 1000
mal höheren krebsrisiko in der ganzen
scheiße und
versteht es einfach nicht wieso arbeiten
der menschen in einem unternehmen die
einfach nachhaltig die menschheit
irgendwie schädigen
oh ja genau jetzt hab ich mal
gegenseitig ab das verstehe ich nicht
aber es ist auch wieder glatt sind wir
von technischen schwierigkeiten zu
monsanto gekommen die an uns aber leute
wie gesagt ist komm jetzt wieder videos
weil ich jetzt aber video videos machen
kann zwar nicht so dass ich keine lust
hatte sondern es ging einfach nicht
natürlich immer noch das ein oder andere
böckchen in reserve und ich hoffe ihr
habt auch noch bock auf jeden fall ganz
ganz herzliches willkommen an all die
leute die dort dran geblieben sind ihr
könnt mir einfach mal in die kommentare
schreiben
wer jetzt sozusagen die durchgängig die
videos geschaut hat und ich strikt an
jedem von euch ein dankesbrief dem ich
sage wie sehr ich euch liebe 1000
zeichen so und den wollen ihr okay zack
so kann es nämlich auch gern hier meint
ich euch wittlicher schritte gerade gar
nicht wie lange wir aufnehmen weil ich
mir darum irgendwie twitter auf ab aber
schaut mir auf jeden fall mal in die
kommentare
ob er jetzt die ganze zeit hier
zugeschaut habt wie es findet es war
natürlich nicht das gleiche ist ganz
klar das verstehe ich auch dass ihr sagt
ja wir haben es kabinett um es kate zu
sehen und nicht krankhaft auch wenn er
ab und zu dabei ist oder öfter dabei ist
aber wie gesagt jetzt bin ich wieder da
für euch und kann wieder videos fertig
machen und hat auch ein paar coole ideen
die werden zusammen umsetzen werden
und ja ich freue mich einfach darauf
dass es jetzt wieder abgehen kann und
dass ich jetzt wieder richtig viel zeit
für mein hobby
youtube ist einfach geil ist einfach
geil und hat es immer die maps immer
vollkommen übertrieben mit shader
okay okay okay das war richtig ski wir
können auch eine runde machen auf jeden
fall die klingen daran geht die von mir
hier müssen wir immer in design und
lobby gehen weil sonst die leute zu sehr
nach schauen manchmal funktioniert das
automatisch in dicken ihr nicht aufkomme
deswegen ist es ein bisschen risky nähe
das ist mir nicht genug dass sap start
sehr gut auf 19 sekunden runter ja ja
ist einfach cool ist haben jetzt auch
einfach hingesetzt gerade erst wieder
angefangen wir haben auch gar nicht
minecraft gespielt in der zeit wird man
rechner wie gesagt geleckt hat hab mich
gerade hingesetzt und es macht einfach
wieder richtig bock jetzt so frei zu
haben keinen stress mit der uni vista
ich studiert hat jetzt einige intensive
projekte noch zum schluss und ich hoffe
dass ich hier nichts und frühstück hat
nämlich gerade
es gibt frühstück das ist jetzt 14 50
und ich genieße das gerade so bisher
einfach so zu entspannen
und ja ich kann es wieder zocken ich
kann wieder aufnehmen das ist alles mega
entspannt ich kann wieder meine projekte
machen ich kann einfach wieder auch mal
einfach nur chillen
ich weiß aber jetzt ist wirklich sehr
lange ziemlich eingespannt und konnte
nicht so wirklich genau 100 prozentig
das machen was ich machen wollte weil
vorschriften und dinge die man so
erledigen muss er bescheid wie das ist
aber jetzt ist das alles wieder anders
und zwar für eine ganze weile auch wenn
hier gerade überhaupt keine listen
finden warum es blutet bitte nicht box
mich nicht von hinten
der container wurde dich oder ich
ein holzscheit immerhin ist zwar auch
ziemlich häufig aber mir egal ich finde
sie aber übrigens richtig dass man
einfach so der jets haben keinen dem
spiel los das vielleicht mich ehrlich
gesagt extrem pixel games in normalem
gibt es ja nicht ich habe jetzt sei auch
überhaupt keine jasper aber hier scheint
noch nicht genug geboren zu sein oder
doch eine neue robbie war sehr gut
august amigos touchpad ist immer mal
wieder rein
sowohl der nächste gegner ist der
nächste gegner ist da hinten ja sehr gut
ich hab mich wunderts aber ehrlich
gesagt dass ich noch ja ich als ich wird
sich angeben oder so auch dass ich noch
dass ich noch so gut drin bin weiß
eigentlich noch ganz gut funktioniert
bei mir ich kann ich gewinne immer noch
meine runden also keine ahnung ich war
ist nie der krasseste aber ich wollte
mal ganz gut spielen denke ich mal
und ja ich gewinne immer meine runden
und bin ich vollkommen zufrieden und
muss sagen es einfach oder prozent ich
geil was hier gerade abgeht
und ja dann kommt natürlich anfang
august der sommerurlaub zwei wochen auf
zusammen mit max also krankhafter und
luca also konkret dass auch dabei das
wird auch heftig da wenn vielleicht auch
videos kommen also krawatte und videos
sowie live machen wir bestimmt auch wenn
wir da das mit dem internet geregelt
kriegen und ja da kommt ist einiges in
petto leute also habt es gibt einiges zu
erwarten
tanzen hingegeben hat leider keine
pfeile mehr
wo hat es kein einziges mal getroffen
mit dem bogen das war wirklich sein muss
man zu holen wir müssen uns holen nein
den haben wir geholt keine ahnung was da
auf einmal los war auf einmal den
nordberg ist jahrtausende und flix ein
halbes jahrhundert weg jahrhundert ich
mein licht jahrhundert liegt jahrhundert
so seltsam auf jeden fall sind wir
wieder im business hier und ich was hat
er da vor redblue shadow pilz wie was
pilz die verpasste per 21
aber ich muss auf den fall ist man
nickenig würde ich jetzt wirklich gerne
killen ich würde wirklich gerne den
gefeilt und ich jetzt einfach killen
aber ich kann nicht weil ich zu naiv
wenn ich hab drei fehlen dreieinhalb
herzen
diese karte ist so trieb ihr müsst ihr
schaut euch das mal an das ist
vollkommen krank hier mit dem shader
sorry aber im deathmatch machen doch
kein frieden so was verstehe ich dann
also keine ahnung ich bin doch gelegt
ich meine kann ich nicht sehen ja keine
ahnung was da gemacht hat der denkt
jetzt auch erkannt ärger machen das ist
nicht der fall
der andere spricht mit sagt dankeschön
ok jetzt nur aufpassen dass der andere
nicht von hinten wegsteckt bis jetzt
nicht das alles ziemlich gut wir so wie
es auch schon 12 dabei wird die letzte
runde
aber ich denke ihr habt auf jeden fall
ein schönes wiedersehens video verdient
finde ich nachdem es so lange gedauert
bis ich wieder gekommen bin
nick reset to do you know you dann mache
ich gut verstehen ich ganz allein es ist
doch mach ich gute butter du weißt doch
gut wenn alles routine
ganz ehrlich wenn einer von euch alles
routine fonds i can't dann schreibt dass
man die kommentare
das wäre so krass ist so ein geiles
sieht was ich persönlich sofort feuer
aber ich weiß nicht was deren einig ich
hätte mich nicht
komm jetzt bitte stirb einfach kannst du
den gefallen tun da kannst du zeigt wo
alte steckt aber auch viel eigen meine
fresse
okay das war's das war es die leute das
erste video ist da ist es vorbei wir im
gewonnen
wir haben uns schön die runden hier
gespielt und am ende noch gewonnen
und ja ich würde sagen wenn ihr euch
einfach freut dass es jetzt wieder
losgeht mit videos zu lasten daumen nach
oben und schreibt einfach in die
kommentare was ihr euch denkt wie euch
gefühlt habe als ich dann hier diese
paar wochen weg war
was jetzt gerade sehen wollt aber wenn
ich jetzt wieder frisch reinkommen kann
ich natürlich auch wieder neue impulse
setzen neue projekte vielleicht bringen
falls irgendwelche ideen habt schreibt
einfach rein da will ich sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder was brauchst du
dich morgen schon wieder kommt nicht nur
tage sondern jeden tag und da will ich
dann haut rein ich freue mich wieder
videos zu machen
macht's gut und shoe co